Did you see that video,
that old man putting the ice on the ground and then pretending you fell?
Oh that's,
yeah.
Allegedly brilliant.
Allegedly.
There's no allegedly for that.
It's amazing.
It's amazing to watch cause he didn't know there was a security camera there.
Tried to collect.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that do that man.
I've seen videos of people doing it at the mall.
They'll like throw a drink down and then slide down on the drink.
We had a guy do at one side and a movie theater I worked at and we had it on
video off so,
and we just showed them the video and then he left and never heard anything
about it.
But he was bitching up a storm like he was hurt.
Watch sky scarves.
Hilarious.
So he's walking.
He looks around chuck some ice on the ground.
Who Bit of an ice stand?
No big deal.
I'm just going to go over here and la Di da Di da.
Okay,
I love this.
Watch this.
He looks around and make sure no one's looking.
Oh,
even felt like a bitch.
I was like holding his strip.
Most ridiculous look at that silly,
silly,
silly man.
The thing about those guys is like anybody that does that kind of shit,
I think the cops,
all they have to do is go,
sure,
what's your social security number?
And then they look up all the shit that he's also done.
Like you don't,
that ain't just a little bit of a scam.
That's a guy who's been scam and it's like in Russia and stuff or other
countries where everyone's doing the insurance scams.
And so to the point where everybody has to have dash cams on their car.
Now there's a lot of that just triggered a story I heard over the weekend.
There was a knot.
It's,
I think this is a story happening in Houston where the cops broke into a house
where they had heard that there was there,
they think they had a warrant.
Uh,
report was that neighbors had called in black tar heroin sales or something like
that at this house.
So they broke in without knocking.
It was like a no knock warrant.
Uh,
the guys at 57 in the house here,
summer break into his house,
gets a shotgun,
shoots one of the cops,
they kill him.
His wife was like,
what the fuck's going on?
She goes to try to grab the other cops gun that had just fallen.
She gets shot.
Two people are dead and it didn't find any heroine.
Oh Geez.
There's like some weed in there or something like that.
And some people are like,
they didn't have a history of doing much from what I read.
That's why I thought of it.
Cause they look back with these guys.
Do they have an arrest history or anything?
And it wasn't anything that they'd found.
At least when I read about it.
Do you remember the one where there was a mayor outside of Washington DC and he,
uh,
they were using his house as an address and it was something with the mail
delivery guy was running weed.
And so the mail delivery guy would come by and uh,
the package was addressed to him,
but he would just keep the package cause he knew that this was this guy's house.
It was on his route and that way,
you know,
as the package came in,
the mail would be his to deliver,
but instead of delivering it,
he would hold onto it.
So they break into the mayor's house?
No,
you know the whole,
the soldier shoot his fucking dogs chewed his dog and he had like one of my dog,
like Marshall.
She's like a super duper sweet dog.
He's a yellow lab,
which is real similar.
I think it was a yellow lab,
might've been golden retriever.
Either way.
They fucking shot at least one of his dogs had they not know it was the mayor's
house.
You think that would be like,
like on a list?
They didn't Google shit or maybe they did.
Maybe they thought fucking the mayor's a drug dealer.
Maybe they're really thought that,
but that kind of shit is dark man.
We just go shoot a golden retriever.
Come on.
You're not a pussy.
And I know you're going in there because you think that this is a real drug
running operation because the cops just got bad information.
Right?
But you're not a pussy.
You don't have to shoot a fucking Labrador stop.
You think that things going to bite you will when it does shoot it then so I'm
going to buy you the fuck out of here.
That's a weird power trip.
Shit thing.
You shoot all dog.
No.
Look,
if a guy's got a wolf and it's off the chain,
it's running at you.
Yeah,
shoot it.
But you breaking into some guy's house and then you shoot his fucking dog.
What if you're wrong?
Like you are a lot.
You cool with shooting someone's fucking dog in front of their kids.
That's what happened to the,
the mayor of this town,
the fucking mayor.
I bet the guy was a mail carrier.
Just thought it was cute to use the mayor's address,
get all the wheat delivered.
Maybe he didn't maybe voted for his opponent.